hold fast to dreams for if dreams die
life is like a broken winged bird that
cannot fly
[Music]
this is star talk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and today we're going to
feature a one-on-one conversation with a
friend of Star Talk Erwin redliner Irwin
is a it's the kind of doctor we all wish
we had he's a medical doctor but he's
way more than that in this episode we
talk about the war in Ukraine its effect
on not only the adults but especially
the children
not only the children who still have
parents but children who are orphaned
children who are War amputees children
who have been emotionally stressed
by this War and what possible
consequences that might have
on their lives and the lives of the
country as well Irwin redliner those of
you who have listened to every one of
our podcasts would have heard him
several times in the past uh he's a
pediatrician and co-founder of the
Children's Health fund also co-founder
of the Ukraine children's Action project
about which we'll hear much more in the
coming minutes and I also have here from
his resume founding director of Columbia
University's national Center for
disaster preparedness
find our interview with him in our
archives learning what that's all about
and it's author of a book the future of
us
what the dreams of children mean to 21st
century of America Irwin welcome back to
Star talk too
thanks Neil always a pleasure to be with
you listen you just got back from the
Ukraine I mean if not hours ago
certainly days ago what were you doing
there specifically well yeah this is our
fourth trip uh there I mean us meaning
Karen Redlin and myself was the other it
was the co-founder with me of Ukraine
children's Action project
our fourth trip there since the most
recent Invasion Invasion by Russia of
Ukraine's land mass and we'll get into
that later but I think uh what we
discovered first of all we got there on
a Sunday evening
and the next morning maybe 11 hours
after we around
arrived at the hotel the Arid sermons
went off in lafif where we were and
announcements were coming across the
hotels PA system go to the basement now
and um we went down to the basement the
electricity was off by that time we
spent five
quality hours uh with uh some colleagues
who were there actually at the hotel to
meet with us uh but we were living the
experience
not not the Destruction part of the
experience but the fear and uncertainty
part of it with everybody else in
Ukraine and I think the main way of
looking at this is that when you
actually visit the place that you're
reading about in the newspaper whether
it's a big disaster uh some other trauma
whatever you're doing
there's a little bit of a gap maybe a
big gap
between the abstract what you're reading
about what you might be seeing even in
television news clips
the gap between that
and the reality of the experience
and for me as a pediatrician who's now
visited uh children's Wards in leviv
multiple times now meaning that I've
actually made what they call rounds
Grand rounds walking through the wards
of the Children's Hospital in Lafave
where many children have been
transferred from the front lines the
battlefields in eastern and southern
Ukraine to relative safely safety in the
western part of Ukraine in leviv
and uh you know it's like I I've seen a
lot Neil I ran a pediatric ICU a big one
in Florida uh years ago I've seen I've
started two child abuse neglect programs
uh I've dealt with children in adversity
and extreme poverty uh for my entire
career but walking around the wards
of the Children's Hospital in leviv and
seeing children with traumatic amputees
from uh being uh in the wrong place when
the missiles were falling near maripool
and uh in Ukraine and I saw an 11 year
old girl recovering from severe head
injuries who also happened to watch
Russian soldiers murder with pistols her
parents right in front of her
so at some point we'll get fair amount
of healing of the physical injuries that
she suffered but I'm not sure that in a
normal full lifetime
she will ever come remotely close to
recovering from the psychological trauma
she saw this is an emergent reality I
think the uh our emotional health you
know we you know growing up we all heard
about are you shell-shocked right or are
you not coming from Vietnam but I don't
know that there was an entire
uh attention of professionals get an
entire sort of branch of professional
healing given unto the emotional
stability of people who've been in war
especially children
well it's happening much more than it
was in World War II or Vietnam with
respect to troops
and secondarily with respect to the
families of troops but really not even
completely enough there but in terms of
civilians in a population the civilians
in Iraq who became the secondary
casualties of our uh Excursion there or
the population of Vietnam when we're
there
um no we don't pay any attention to that
whatsoever so being there is a is is a
pretty remarkable experience from that
point of view and you know these uh the
children
before the war
there were seven half million children
in Ukraine the child population
five million of them two-thirds have
been displaced
uh Within
either half of them half of them have
been displaced Within
Ukraine itself in the western part half
of them became part of the refugee
population most of which are in Poland
but many other countries as well
these children
were a traumatized and B experiencing
long-term educational disruption
and for Karen and me that's
that's really a double whammy that is
very difficult for children to get over
so you think about two-thirds of the
country which be equivalent to about 50
million children in the United States
being suddenly
displaced by War
um you know
to try to calculate how we're going to
deal with that
and Preserve the dreams and aspirations
and potential productivity of these
children in the future
it's actually not clear so our
foundation is focused on those two
things the Ukraine children's Action
Project yes Ukraine children's Action
project is actually focused on this
primarily but not entirely this double
agenda first
that we're interested in how can these
psychological
trauma be addressed by Ukraine in
general and how can we make sure that
children are not missing school while
they're waiting for the war to end
and by the way I would like to note that
there was just some recent reports about
educational
achievement of American kids after the
pandemic
where there's been a dramatic
terrifying drop off in educational
capabilities and um where children are
in the school system at this point so
pandemic which had many children out of
school for a long time especially in
cities like New York is taking a toll on
where children are educationally and
imagine that happening in large scale
with a lot of this physical trauma on
top of it
so obviously you're gonna you're
treating
um physical trauma first because a
person can die without proper uh
treatment but the uh what about and then
the emotional trauma you have to see how
that manifests right as time goes on
presumably there'll be a whole
scholarship that will rise up around
like you said we don't you don't know
what to do
about it right and so you have to you
need clever people inventive people
people who have thought about it in
other ways perhaps all coming together
to try to develop some kind of plan
for this what about sort of the the
supply chain of food and nutrition and
medicines right so what it what turns
out to be
uh is the case that the large
International organizations uh the uh
International Red Cross save the
children UNICEF are very very good at
meeting the initial needs the human
these are called the humanitarian needs
protecting children making sure that
everybody has enough to eat that they're
getting acute medical care what they're
kind of lousy at I hope nobody strikes
me down for this is paying attention to
the massive psychological trauma and
educational continuity
and you know Karen is actually on the
working groups for uh education and
mental health for children that's been
organized by uh UNICEF
so she's in the mix and talking to these
agencies and it's like not enough on
their radar so they're getting millions
and millions of dollars you know and
it's not clear
where the dollars are going with respect
to those two big issues that I've I've
been talking about
so it's not so much that they're bad at
it I mean I don't ever remember that
being in their mission statement or is
it and I just missed it it's it's not
really in their mission statement they
are really focused on the more dramatic
immediate needs you know here's food for
children in refugee camps here's his
Waters
right so you know that's that's the case
so how did you actually you didn't just
book a Delta Airlines flight and land in
Ukraine how did you get into Ukraine
well we actually booked a lot Polish
Airlines flight and we did that because
a very close friend of ours for many
many years
Joan Baez the iconic
American
yes right in recent years he's taken up
portrait painting and she's gotten
spectacularly good at it
and one of the things she did she
painted a portrait right after the war
story started of President zielinski of
Ukraine
and she called me up and said I just
paid this portrait I'll send you she
emailed me a picture a copy of it and
and said what what should I do with the
what should I do with this to help the
the cause I said why don't we make
prints
print up them as many as you feel like
and we'll sell them
and we'll use the money to help the
effort in Ukraine she printed up 250
copies sold them for 515 a piece raised
about 125 000 and said okay here's the
money what do we do with it
and that prompted me to want to go there
to Ukraine and actually meet with
organizations on the ground the
International Medical Corps and uh
Doctors Without Borders and many other
organizations we decided that that money
would go to the international medical
Corps
but once I got hooked like that
Karen and I got hooked
we couldn't leave it we couldn't stop
that was the first visit that we made
there in April
in may we set up a new not-for-profit
Foundation the Ukraine children's Action
project
and we've just come back from our fourth
visit there
and Neil it's been it's been amazing
we've met with the Mayors and the
governors of leviv city and leviv
Province we've put the mayor of Warsaw
Poland on our Advisory Group
uh we have very close friends now in
government and also the major agencies
that are working there
and we're able to both deliver things
to Children and Families but also serve
as advocates how are we going to scale
up what we do we're a tiny organization
but we have a you know we're so what's
the cliche we're hitting above our
weight here because boxing above your
weight yeah boxing above our way
punching above her weight yeah and we
can influence and we do influence
people just help figure out how to scale
up what we're doing for example
uh we're working with members of the
Ukraine Parliament
uh we've just developed with the team at
Columbia University
a uh a online program to train teachers
how to deal with classrooms full of
traumatized children
almost finished it's going to be
translated to Ukraine and to polish and
it's going to be available in leviv and
Ukraine but parliament of Ukraine is
interested in scaling it up so that
every teacher in Ukraine
has access to may be required to take
this particular training program
so this is like advocacy in action we're
not just talking about it or writing
about it which I try to do as much as
possible but it's part of our mission is
to get things scaled up or influence
people to scale up and by the way I hope
you're keeping very good notes because
this sounds like a playbook for any
future such conflict where you have uh
traumatized physically injured children
that are like refugees or otherwise in
Warfare because I don't know that the
species
human beings are mature enough to not
have War ever again
so to the extent that you are
inventing Solutions here
um the the record of that will be of
immense uh incalculable value going
forward
yeah well to that point we're actually
keeping very very detailed notes and I I
like the idea that you called it a
Playbook because I think that's what it
will be you know there's an assumption
that the big International ngos you know
non-governmental organizations and
governments have already absorbed this
you know I was in the first big disaster
I went to was 1976.
um which was a massive earthquake in
Guatemala
and I saw things I mean I couldn't
believe it I was in Ethiopia in the in
the 80s during during the famine there
and it's the same over and over again
the immediate needs are you know pretty
well met but nobody has been paying
attention to the psychological trauma
and what happens to children who don't
go to school for a couple years
you know I spoke to him in fact just
that I spoke to a nine-year-old
girl with her family there were syrians
in a refugee camp in northern Greece in
2017.
and like I also I mean a pediatrician a
grandfather so I was talking to them
through a translator and I asked the
nine-year-old girl
what do you want to be when you grow up
beautiful young Syrian kid looked much
like my then nine-year-old granddaughter
at the time but she says to me with a
big smile on her face I want to be a
doctor
and even to this day I feel like
it's tough talking about this she says
to me you know I want to be a doctor I
know she hasn't been to school in three
years I know that she's likely to be in
that refugee camp a sparse horrible
place in the middle of nowhere in Greece
she's likely to be there for another
decade
and I'm thinking the chances of this kid
becoming a doctor essentially nil
as opposed to my granddaughter who could
be whatever the hell she wants to be
she's smart she's cute she's whatever
and I think that kind of disparity that
fundamental inequity like in addition to
what you were saying Neil that war is
always going to be inevitable like major
natural disasters we're living with war
for as long as we can see far into the
future as we can see
but so is the inequitable treatment of
children in our world and that's
something I've just been dedicated and
trying to figure out
tell me about the emergent Technologies
the communication Technologies uh you
know the starlink satellites the
internet social media
um are these helpful or or not
in trying to recover some sense of a
social cultural development so the
shorthand for that is normalcy
we're trying to establish normalcy
starting with the idea of children not
being damaged by the ongoing
psychological trauma that they're
receiving and especially getting
children back to school
so the role for technology is huge and
we're already deploying it in the
training for teachers who deal with
psychologically uh affected children and
we're dealing with the the issue of
educational continuity
by despying and distributing a lot of
tablets and upload it into those tablets
are the full curricula I mean in the
summertime Ukraine had a divert some of
the funding for education to the
military for obvious reasons as a result
of which every fifth grader did not get
the textbooks they need
um and we were going to buy textbooks
but they said could we possibly get
tablets we said of course makes total
sense so we're Distributing like crazy
now as many as we can buy which depends
on how much money we can raise
and this is what we're doing so children
will be holding in their hands
technology their teachers will be their
Mental Health Providers will be and
their parents will be
and I think that technology you know is
key
to being able to do something
substantive and enduring for the
children that really need it in Ukraine
and also the ones who
who are refugees outside of Ukraine so
you've been trying to get inside kids
heads forever trying to see the world
through their lens
um in your book the future of us
what the dreams of children mean to 21st
century America uh what what were you
what what was the major theme there that
drove the contents of the book well it
was by the way it was a theme that
came very powerfully to us in Ukraine a
week and a half ago
it is that one of the you know children
developed from infancy and they
developed uh you know how to meet their
basic needs they they uh need to
identify themselves as individuals
separate from their parents all that
happens but the greatest gift
that children have is the ability to
dream to Aspire
to have a vision of the future and this
is what I think is so damaging when we
deprive Children of the ability to dream
and then manifest those dreams and the
first half of that book the future of us
is all about these children you know
homeless kids in Brooklyn one kid told
me he wanted to be a paleontologist
a 10 year old gaunt impoverished child
I said
do you know what that means William he
said a young guy who looks for dinosaur
bones he said right how do you know
about that
the kid on the back of our Mobile
Medical unit where I'm treating him
reaches in his pocket
picks up picks out a yellowed newspaper
clipping from The New York Times about a
paleontologist out west somebody had
given him this it was yellow it was old
but he he hung on to that he clung to it
and again you know
is was William able to become a
paleontologist in our wildest
imaginations
I don't think so and that's the tragedy
of children who live in adversity but
anyway here's what happened in Ukraine
so we went to so I told you the first
day we were there on a Monday the
bombing started in Ukraine and uh and uh
the capital
in the capital and in leviv where we
were and um you know the sirens were
going off we kept going down into the
shelters and stuff but on Thursday we
had a meeting at an orphanage in the
outskirts of Lev
on Monday when the bombings had started
the staff brought these children into a
shelter
I mean they could hear and see the smoke
and the explosions
it was Pitch Black there was no
electricity and there was no cell phone
service for the adult staff
the kids cried that first Monday for
five hours straight
so two things there three days later
I'm up there at the orphan it's a
beautiful sunny day and a really nice
modest
grounds of this orphanage and I said I
wanted to speak to the uh his children
they brought a dozen kids
to see me to visit with me and we have
this on videotape and lots of pictures
but
my usual Mo I said to the kids all right
through a translator
I'd like to know what you'd like to how
old you are and what you'd like to be
when you grow up
and these are kids now orphans who had
come from a completely bombed out town
in eastern Ukraine
and they say I want to be a program a
computer programmer
I want to be a builder I want to be a
manicurist I want to some kid said to me
I want to be a jeweler
I said you know my ring broke I wonder
would you help me if you were absolutely
I'm going around there's two kids who
want to be singers and I swear to God
and I have it on tape so you don't have
to trust my words here but I get to the
last kid a really adorable little 11
year old girl what do you want to be
ready girl says I want to be president
I said president of Ukraine she says
just for emphasis
and I'm
I'm blown away you know I don't it's
like this is what I wrote about in this
book these kids with dreams in the face
of the impossible adversity
and what a crime against humanity
for us to wow these dreams to be
smothered eventually by our inability to
manage the adversities they live in and
live with
so
this is I guess if I had to Define what
I've been doing for these last 50 years
it's been trying to come to grips with
that and initially I was really you know
I'm a doctor I was doing Healthcare and
all that it's great
at some point about
I don't know 10 years ago I said this is
Healthcare is not enough I care about
the success of these children and by the
way the success of children
is greatly related to the success of our
society oh yeah our productivity our
ability to read to create happy
comfortable productive communities
depends on how we manage the adversities
that many children live with in my
opinion
so that's where things are and that's
where it all came came back to me and
and Stark
language and feelings uh a couple of
things so the the concept of that book
was in a way sort of a baptism for you
to think about how to even
Embrace this problem or how to how to
how to think about the problem
before you even come up with a solution
if there is one yeah the solution is can
we all get along right the adults all
right the kids are not the ones out
there fighting each other it's the
grown-ups
so
yeah and fighting each other all kinds
of ways it's not just War think about
what's happening in the United States
but you know we're dealing with a very
very divided Society you know and you
know if how do we make progress on the
things that really matter
if we're storming the capital in an
Insurrection if we're you know refining
each other we're anti-semitic racist
factions that are armed growing up here
it's like we we don't have the mental
space in some ways to really get to the
root of what we need to do which is
something we all have to work on I think
we all can work on right but it's a big
challenge
let me ask you about another part of
your expertise uh one of our as I said
at the top of the show one of my
interviews with you were about your role
as a disaster preparedness uh expert and
disaster not just oh uh uh we're talking
about disasters on a level that most
people do not think about where the
transportation grid is taken out there
you know the the water supply the the on
a level where oh my gosh what are the
next steps when you see the destruction
in Ukraine such as what would occur in
most War zones how does all that get
rebuilt
What what is the
what I guess you have it has to end
first
but who's making it end and once it ends
how do you do you rebuild do people move
back in uh how do I I've never even
thought about that so I I just I have a
talk that I've been giving lately to
medical students and so on and other
groups and part of that talk is about
the recovery of Ukraine that's the word
I was looking for what what is that
about and uh you know a couple of months
ago president zielinski said it's going
to take 750 billion dollars
to manage the recovery of Ukraine
I think it's going to be double that but
whatever it is the reason it's so
expensive
is obvious the we're talking about full
cities that have been absolutely leveled
uh and there's the physical issue of
rebuilding the cities fixing the highly
damaged infrastructure from the
electrical grid to the fuel supply lines
and everything you can think of the
transportation modalities everything
but then there's the human elements of
recovery which again comes back to what
do we have to do for the people that
have been psychologically traumatized if
we have kids that are not getting
educated
you know Ukraine only has about 18 of
its population in our children
we need really all of them to be fully
functional
but if we have so many of them damaged
and have had their education disrupted
what's going on with that we have to do
a lot of Remy remediation
of children of that psychological trauma
and educational disruption so there's a
lot of human issues involved also but
like you said Neil Step One Stop the
damn War we've got to get this war to
stop and you know there's there's
growing let's say controversy about what
needs to happen here
so for many ukrainians including the
president
we just want to we just want to beat the
Russians into submission and I can
totally understand that what was was
once a war for territory is now a war of
pure terrorism
there's no other reason to be bombing
the capital and to be bombing places
like David where people have come have
gone to be safe
so it's a terror War at this point so
you can imagine that if you're a
Ukrainian
and your City was destroyed and friends
and family killed you would not be
looking for negotiation
on the other hand if you're in the
United States
if you're uh a leader in one of the
Western European countries that's
pouring a lot of money and arms there
you do not have an inexhaustible
compassion and ability to support a
never-ending war with the Russians until
they're completely completely beaten
and I think we're going to have to face
that controversy at some point but
whatever it is at this point for me as a
pediatrician
whatever it takes to stop it right now
is what I would like to see because
every day brings more destruction and
More Death Etc so I'm not looking at
this geopolitically I'm looking at this
as it has a job who cares about children
so forgive me but that's that's where
I'm coming from do is there any
knowledge or Insight from
uh children
in the second world war who were
displaced I mean a lot of cities were
bombed out uh over across multiple
countries surely there's some
scholarship on that some research
you know what's a complicated
research question
and whatever little research was
actually done very little of it close to
zero
was actually understood adopted and put
into play in any Modern War it's amazing
to me I I would shudder to think what's
going on in Syria in Iraq and Vietnam
still I mean we don't learn from past
experiences about much of anything you
and your book
and brilliantly talked about some of the
great advances that we've made the
timeline was it's one of the things I
was really I just was staring at that
Neil because like maybe there's hope for
us is what I'm thinking but when it
comes to advances in The Human Condition
and by the way we have eliminated a fair
amount of poverty and hunger in Africa
but by there's still a billion kids that
are that are hungry every day with food
insecurity and so on so the progress
we've made technologically
is significantly significantly greater
than the progress we've made on a human
level
and
look this is I don't know and you you
know far better than I do is this just
a condition of our species is this what
we basically have to live with or die
with I mean is this I don't know I'm
asking rhetorically but you know this is
this is where we are as far as I'm
concerned
um
well there are there is the promising
data on the fact that fewer people today
are living in poverty than in past
decades and more people are living
longer there's some sort of blunt
uh statistics that do point in a
positive direction the the war in the
Ukraine I mean I it you mentioned my
book in in the chapter on conflict and
resolution I I did the calculation right
uh in the second world war between 1939
and 1945 1
000 people per hour
were killed in the service of that war
you just take the total death toll
divide it out you get a thousand per
hour so so whatever we were living with
back then
if I think in almost every metric it was
much much worse than whatever we're
contending with today
it's just hard to see it and feel it
that way because where you know we don't
live for 200 years right we live no
whatever we do yeah and we don't have
the the longest of views on which to
analyze this but how what hope do you
bring I mean I I'm almost in tears
hearing every place you've been in the
past 50 years you know like you said the
I only saw photos of that that
earthquake okay and you know I like you
said there's this gap between your
awareness that something is real and
whether you feel that that something is
real and that Gap is makes all the
difference between uh being a
dispassionate Observer and being a
participant so to just see this list of
places you have been to to witness
how do you wake up and what what do you
what do you
looking at the world what positive
thoughts can you possibly summon for
yourself and for us well there's two
huge things actually two huge things and
I get this question mostly from my
relatives but
when I when I hear
an 11 year old orphaned kid from a
destroyed City in Ukraine now living in
an orphanage say that she wants to be
president or the kid behind her says he
wants to be a computer programmer I say
man oh man if these kids can sustain
a dream
a real dream
given what they're experiencing the
least I can do is try to keep my spirits
up and the other factor I must say
is the existence of my grandchildren
I feel like I don't have a choice I'm
not going to sit around soaking
when my my six-year-old grandson was
here in hanging out a couple hours ago
on that my oldest is eight is uh 22 now
actually and they give me the strength
and also
the inability to get too despondent
about everything but but the big thing
is really the sustaining of Dreams by
children and adversity is like a
freaking tonic to me it is it is Geritol
if you remember so nobody remembers
Jared's all no no it's a thing that only
old guys can talk about this but right
right but I want to say something else
you know
the other thing that's
made me think a lot is the speed in
which we make progress yes there's less
poverty including less property in
Africa
um there's less property in the United
States in children but it's taking so
long when I was my first job was in east
Arkansas
uh a in 1971 I was the director of a
clinic
in the six poorest county in America
there and uh it was Rife with it was
it was overrun with racism and poverty I
would go on house calls and be be
followed at night with these guys in
pickup trucks in the Ku Klux Klan the
White Citizens Council with with gun
racks in the back
um yet I was you know I was a Kennedy
Johnson kid
so I would tell the staff and everyone
that would listen that you know what 10
or 15 years we'd be done with racism in
America and we would end child poverty
and everyone would have health care that
would take maybe I thought in 1971 maybe
10 years maybe 15
and here we are I'm at the end of my
life Neil and we still have what we see
around us
I don't understand how that could be and
I have a son that's a doctor a wonderful
young guy Michael and
I'm telling you his wife also a doctor I
tell my kids my actual children not the
grandchildren
I'm leaving you a mess I'm so I'm sorry
I'm sorry my generation didn't make the
things happen that I thought was going
to happen
a half a century ago
all right well the Arc of progress as
has been described
whatever
whatever is the slope of that Arc it
you'd still rather be living today than
40 years ago for sure no no argument no
arguments there and I'm reminded of a
few lines from a poem by Langston Hughes
where he says
um hold fast to dreams for if dreams die
life is like a broken winged bird that
cannot fly
well I'm getting the chills from you
reciting that verse and uh
I think I'm gonna have I think I'm gonna
make that into something I can hang on
my wall in front of me so thanks
Langston Hughes yeah so you're our
and you're not a dream catcher so much
as a dream enabler perhaps a dream
documenter which we need we all need
that
um Erwin thank you for this I think your
third appearance on Star Talk and we'd
look forward to many more maybe it's
progress thanks for the reports on not
only Ukraine but so many of your other
fascinating projects just trying to make
a better world for for especially those
directly affected but in the end for us
all so but look who's talking Neil
you've been trying to make a better
world since you learned how to speak and
all right you know your contributions to
our society I'm not just saying this
it's like it's amazing and inspiring to
me so just trying to get people to look
up yeah yeah we'll talk all right all
right Dr Erwin redliner uh thanks for
being here I this has been a one-on-one
conversation with someone who's at the
center of the challenges we Face In This
Modern World when grown-ups can't get
along and the real casualty there is the
next Generation who really have
our future
in their hands or not so much their
hands but in their dreams
and it's kind of Our obligation to them
to make sure they don't get squashed in
this glorious beautiful world
called Earth Neil deGrasse Tyson
it's looking up
[Music]